monsieur le président mes chers amis
m'ont vient finalement la part la plus
sympathique puisque l'année 2015 a
plutôt été une belle année électorale
alors je ne sais pas si on va avoir les
cartes en même temps mais après le
succès des élections municipales de mars
après puisque joie de nombreux sénateurs
la victoire au sénat en septembre 2014
qui nous a permis de reprendre le sénat
nous avons eu monsieur le président
après votre élection les élections
départementales
alors c'est simple les élections
départementales nous ont permis en
réalité de passer d'un pays à l'époque
de 41 départements gérés par nos
familles politiques à 68 départements
nous avons progressé de 27 départements
en une seule élection c'est vrai que
jusque là le renouvellement était à
moitié
mais le renouvellement n'était jamais
supérieurs pour les mouvements gauche
droite à dix départements ce qui veut
dire que c'est la première fois sous la
vème a donné que le basculement a été
aussi fort et que nous avons une aussi
grande progression pour les départements
des départements classiquement
socialiste des bouches du rhône le nord
ont basculé des départements plus
symbolique l'essonne de manuel valls
la corrèze du président au lendemain
c'est vrai du président chirac avant ont
basculé nous avons remporté monsieur le
président plus de 60 % des sièges de
conseillers départementaux
c'était une magnifique victoire avec un
renouvellement extrêmement fort puisque
naturellement beaucoup de jeunes ont été
élus à la fois comme conseillers
départementaux comme président des
conseils départementaux
par la suite nous avons eu les élections
municipales partielles jouer la carte
d'ailleurs pour les conseils
départementaux
rapidement vous voyez bien sûr le bleu
qui l'emportent très largement en 2015
par rapport à ce qui était la carte
précédente s'est pas encore assez ça
veut dire qu'il ya encore des progrès à
faire pour
prendre enfin quand même la carte de
france s'est nettement bleury en mars
nous avons eu ensuite les élections
municipales partielles et à ces
élections municipales partielles ajaccio
à thionville à noisy-le-grand avec le
magnifique succès de brigitte pacini en
seine-saint-denis et dans votre
département monsieur le président dans
les hauts-de-seine où nous avons repris
reconquis non les avais par laval
auparavant à asnières par exemple ou
plus tôt mais nous avons pris par
exemple clichy clichy ville socialiste
peu plus d'un siècle et la conquête de
clichy nous a permis de faire en sorte
que dans le département des
hauts-de-seine et je vois beaucoup
d'élus des hauts-de-seine ici n'y a plus
une seule ville gérée par le parti
socialiste
je souhaite que ce soit le cas un peu
partout bras en attendant nous avons eu
des municipales partielles extrêmement
positive et puis les élections
régionales
nous allons voir la carte des régions
c'est simple chacun s'en souvient 2010
nous n'avons conservé en métropole que
l'alsace
regardez regardez la carte de 2010 ça
fait peur ou ça fait pitié
du rose partout une toute petite tâche
de bleu seulement 4% des français de
métropole étaient gérés par des élus ump
ou udi à l'époque
voilà la carte après alors bien sûr les
médias peuvent faire des commentaires
mais regardez la carte la carte nouvelle
la carte qui a permis après les
élections de décembre 2015 de faire que
nous passons à cette région vient en
réalité correspondent à 11 rue ancien
bus trois étaient regroupés et nous
passons de 4% de la population française
qui était gérée par l'ump udi à 68%
alors quand on nous dit qui a gagné ba
qui a gagné
les socialistes en 2010 gérer 96% des
français de métropole en 2015 32% ont
perdu la gestion de deux tiers des
français qu'ils avaient qui a gagné
naturellement monsieur le président les
républicains puisque nous nous passons
de 4% 68% et nous avons conservé la
réunion malgré une alliance il faut bien
le dire un peu contre nature entre la
gauche et le modem alors cette ville
c'est victoire aux régionales l'ont été
il faut bien le dire aussi
malgré les triangulaires malgré la
présence l'amplification des scores du
front national
mais monsieur le président vous le
disiez vous mêmes dans tous vos discours
au moment des élections départementales
toute la presse nous annoncer que ray au
moins deux ou trois départements gérés
par le front national au moment des
élections régionales ou moins de régions
au front national et parce que nous
avons tenu parce que nous avons été
fermes sur nos positions
il n'y a pas un seul président de
conseil départemental par un seul
président de conseil régional
appartenant au front national est
aujourd'hui les républicains et leurs
alliés de l'udps et y gère l'essentiel
du territoire
alors nous allons préparer bien sûr les
prochaines élections
moi je vous dis puisque je vois ici
beaucoup de gens qui ont participé à la
victoire au départemental à la victoire
régionale joie même certains de ceux qui
ont gagné les élections municipales
partielles
nous sommes prêts monsieur le président
après les élections présidentielles de
2017 que nous allons naturellement
gagner nous gagnerons très largement les
législatives